the TV Owen for platform provides
analysis sections for many types of data
a whole section for next-generation
sequencing and microarray data
transcriptomics genomics and epigenetics
DNA and RNA a section and development
for mass spec data a section for
structural data for small molecules and
protein structures and a whole section
dedicated to modeling machine learning
multi-omics integration and utility
scripts each section has the same
interface upload data
[Music]
build your high plank
[Music]
[Applause]
run the pipeline and download results
[Applause]
some pipelines take minutes some hours
some days and some even take weeks when
your pipeline is finished you will
receive an email or just refresh the
page some pipelines have visual outputs
sum output tables in some you can even
find an R script that you can run or
modify want to learn more take our free
courses on edu T - bio info you can also
request a free demo account or join one
of our workshops
[Music]